scarlet i'm going to start with you
because you've had the opportunity to
work with some of the best of the best
directors on voice performances sprite
jones west anderson i can go on and on
so what is something about the voice
acting directing greats that you think
stays consistent then what's something
about garth that stands out i mean you
know working for wes and spike i mean
both of those directors are
are extremely one thing they share is
they're both um
very very
specific uh like they they hear it in
their head and i think they know
when it sounds right to them like
there's a musicality to their
to their dialogue um
and
i yeah i i mean that's that's some i and
i love the figuring out of the puzzle of
what that is and like helping them
kind of even if they can hear it like
helping them
sort of
like
put that to
the test you know and like
you know i it's the pro the creative
process
um is very exciting when a director has
you know a
vision for something or like has a kind
of a
musical mind in that way and
um
garth i think is you know
he
also similarly has like he knows when
the pitch is right above performance i
think um
you know like he can
he knows when he's got it and he he's
always like he listens for the
little nuances of
vocal performance and
and like calls them out and appreciates
them and like pushes them and stuff like
that he's just he's he's brilliant he's
an amazing writer and um
i guess that's what the three people
have in common they're all shines
through in this movie quite a bit
uh tori so last one was your first
feature second time around what is a a
lesson or a takeaway learned making the
first thing that you were actually able
to apply on this one yeah wow i i think
i i mean i stepped into
the first film as just like a complete
noob i was like i i don't know what i'm
doing but like thank you for
like hiring me for this it's incredible
um it's pretty like it was very much a
dream role because you know as a singer
it's like i get to sing in the movie i
get to
you know kind of dip my feet into acting
more and um
so yeah i guess coming from that like
starting there and then now doing the
second movie i guess i had just more
context for how this all works because
it was literally my first
uh you know my first time doing a movie
so
it was cool just to like be at the
premiere and then see you know how it
all turned out meet the cast like
the whole experience experience was
great and then stepping into the second
one it was just a little bit more
confidence of like okay now i kind of
get how this whole thing works and just
just you know feeding off of what um
scarlett was saying about working with
garth i think
just having a director like him and it
being you know my first movie and i
think for him his first uh animated
movie as well and so i feel like we kind
of shared that and it was like two kids
just like trying to figure it out and
bounce off of each other and um you know
just echoing everything that you said
about him he's just like a dream to work
with so i think that helped me a lot too
before they kick me out of here i'm a
little obsessed with the fact that
you're producing more and more and i
love hearing that so i was reading a
little bit about the non-black widow mcu
thing you're producing and i was just
wondering what inspired the drive to
keep contributing to the franchise but
in that specific capacity and what are
you looking forward to bringing to sets
as a producer that maybe you wish you
had on prior sets
um you know i think i
i've worked for 30 years which is insane
um when i say it out loud but um i just
i think i just understand um
how production i just i understand the
efficiency of how productions
run and um
what is
like
how you kind of
like thin the fat on a production i
guess and make things so well oiled and
um you know i've learned that like the
fish rots from the head which is very
very true in i think any creative space
but particularly like a production that
involves
you know many hundreds of people and so
um
yeah just
working with people that you know want
to be there and all want to
creatively contribute to the same kind
of
idea and uh
you know making building that kind of
creative family i think is is something
i'm really excited about um as i
you know produce more and more things
for other people
um
you know i mean as far as marvel goes i
i you know
it's like working with family there
marvel has like some of the best ip
ever and so
um and you can really dream big there
and um nothing's ever off the table and
there's like you kind of throw all these
like kind of blue sky ideas around and
see what sticks and i just i i
it's like a dream
it's like a creative playground that's
just like a dream so um
yeah and it's
again it's like you have that shorthand
with
my fellow
creatives there that you know comes from
being
in the
world for 10 years with those guys so
psyched to see you make the most of that
thank you also keep making more of these
you